hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith in today's best picture
close-up the filmmakers behind gravity
visit the Academy to share how they
created a whole new kind of movie going
experience fasten your seat belts
we wanted a story where it was just a
one-character of her coming adversity
and where for 90 minutes you would have
the audience grab to the edge of their
seats but at the same time without
loosing the rhythm and without losing
the suspense you could juggle various
themes when we started trying to find
that context that was metaphorically
very rich and that would let us express
all those themes we decided space was a
great context for the story it says
scenario that is very fit it's filled
with adversities and it's also the
journey of a character back to life you
know it's this gravitational pulsing
metaphorically very interesting I
thought it was going to be a
conventional film with a fair amount of
visual effects but when we start trying
the conventional techniques they just it
was very clear immediately that we
needed to invent new tools to do the
thing we didn't have a clue what we were
doing we really didn't when we started
we began this process Alfonso had this
idea of shooting these this film with
these incredibly long shots without cuts
which meant there was nowhere to hide he
couldn't hide the 0:g or the micro G so
we needed to come up with this
technology with which to make that real
he wanted to create a completely
immersive experience there's light boxes
a cube that is nine by nine and is all
the walls inside are LED screens and
they act the actors were in the middle
in very uncomfortable Greeks so
everything in the queue was projecting
the virtual reality of the character I
realized we've been so cushioned and so
spoon-fed by amazing production
designers wardrobe everyone is there to
give you another layer to help make your
job easier and in a strange ways is
opposite as I thought this was when I
started I was fighting it and I was
frustrated and I didn't know how to
operate eventually that Baron sort of
you know no humans no word of note no
crutches around that sort of aspect of
this film ended up being my guide and my
help as well
you know so you went I don't have what
I'm used to this comfortable
I'm in pain I'm frustrated I don't
understand I'm lost and my head is about
to pop and you go I'm sure that's what
it feels like to be where she is for me
projects in general always start with a
good screenplay because you can't make a
good film out of a bad screenplay ever
and it's Alfonzo and I wanted to work
with Alfonso and Sandhya I'd been
friends for a long long time we've never
worked together and so there was there
was no argument not to do it it was just
a great opportunity for me I was I was
thrilled to be there and to be in
support and help in any way I could and
a film that I think is masterful to see
the Best Picture winners in action on
Oscar Sunday check out the Oscars
backstage show on the watch ABC app
we'll see you later